joining us here however on the rich eyes
and show is somebody who
uh i i truly appreciate his work i've
gotten uh to
meet him and uh i'm appreciative of him
saying yes when i said on behalf of all
jets fans i think
i need to have this man on mark
schlereth and all 10 of his fingers here
on the rich eisen show how are you mark
i'm doing great man always good to catch
up with you rich always good to catch up
with you
what's going on with you these days
anything going on with you these days
mark what's going on yeah you know i
mean i'm just
i'm just grinding man i'm doing my radio
show in denver
obviously i'm doing uh your stinking
truth yep
what's that you're doing the stinking
truth podcast as well
podcast and uh right now i've just been
kind of grinding on film and studying
football and getting ready for another
nfl season on fox
so um you know which is always fun i
i i've had the opportunity here the last
couple of years to consult for a couple
of teams and
kind of more more about run game and
offensive line play and how to put all
that together i think one of the things
that have been lost
uh in the nfl and i mean you cover the
league so you understand this
one of the things that have been lost
the more we get away from practice the
more we get away from contact the more
we get away
from being together the more nuance is
lost in the game
and so i think one of the things that
coaches try to bring back is
some of the nuance some of the things
and techniques that we can work on
um and we can understand that better
helps our players grow in this game
when we can't be on the football field
as much so
it's one of those things kind of a
little niche that i have found for
myself here
in the last few years while working for
fox and doing games every sunday
okay so you're saying mark schlereth
that uh
getting on the field and getting coached
up is important so you're saying that
the
the the value of a valuable head coach
could not be any higher it's what you're
saying right mark what are you saying
yeah i think i think head coaching i
think coaching in general i think
consistent coaching i think all that
stuff is
incredibly important okay certainly so
if you hire a new head coach and you
think you've hit on that new head coach
that whatever may
have happened in previous regimes that
might have nothing to do with whatever's
happening from here on out would you say
that that is a
a well-established potential in the nfl
well
certainly certainly there is potential
for that to be true
yes and i know what you're getting i
mean i'm not you know i i
i've got it figured out rich um you
lined up
very smart mark and you're you're a
sharp man you're a sharp man you've got
infant skills i understand that
so yeah you see what i'm getting at
right
yeah no no i and i will tell you robert
saula
uh one of the guys who mentors me is
mike shanahan mike shanahan
obviously connected kyle shanahan his
son head coach of the
san francisco 49ers robert sala was the
defensive coordinator so i spent time at
mike shanahan's
house learning football and one of the
things you know when you're a player
you watch the game rich through the
straw hole with which or through the
prism with which you you played it right
yes and so when you get into the booth
oftentimes one of the things that you
need to do is expand the aperture
and open up your eyes and have a more
global perspective of the game
so i spend a lot of time with shanahan
as a matter of fact a couple years
ago uh two years ago i watched every
install meeting that robert sala put in
as a defensive coordinator
for the 49ers so i watched every one of
their meetings put in their entire
defense watch the coverages and how the
fronts and the coverages work together
the linebacking corps
the whole nine yards he is one of my
favorite people in the national football
league
he is a leader of men he is a smart
coach he's all those things and i think
that is i think it's tremendous higher
for the new york jets
that being said as i always say had the
games been played on paper i would have
spent a lot less time on an operating
table
it takes more than that it takes the
right character men joe gibbs said this
to me when i first came in the league he
said to our team all the time
you know what great athletes will win
you are make plays in the first three
quarters character
men that care about each other and are
willing to sacrifice
win games in the fourth quarter and so
there is a cultural aspect to playing
this game and playing this game
well yes that has to take place and i
think that's the thing that misses
most people that are fans of football
think it's just about good players
and that is that is part of the equation
but that's not the entirety of the
equation but
i think you saw mark as your comments on
our buddy mcafee show
on friday that to say you know
uh to uh the jets fan base that their
entire history
is filled with stinking to use a phrase
and
uh thus having another quarterback
brought in with a new regime
the reset button that's been hit that
everybody's now believing in
should just is just wiped off the face
i think and and you're also seeing a way
also a very fragile
fan base mark a very fragile thing yes
i can understand why i've gone through
the last i've gone through the last six
seasons here as a bronco guy that does a
radio show every day i understand
fragility uh and i understand how
fleeting
winning games is you're 100 right you
know my
my basic comments on pat's show was not
about the jets in general
it was about the state of quarterbacks
coming out of the draft in this league
and the way the league
covets those and and moves those guys up
in the draft based upon the position
that they play and
if you just look at the recent history
you know there was a stat that went
around from 2009 to 2016 22 first round
draft
choices at the quarterback position were
taken none of them are with their
current team that drafted them
it's a really hard thing to be great and
when you come into a situation
where you are supposed to be the savior
you know i look at it this way rich i
think there's about four quarterbacks in
the league that cover warts
the rest of the quarterbacks in the
league expose them and so when you come
in as a young quarterback and you don't
you know you don't necessarily
understand the game and you haven't
played at that level with that level of
player around you
and you're asked to go be the savior of
the franchise whether it's the jets or
whether it's the
jacksonville jaguars i don't care who it
is it's a really tough task
and you know people have this
misconception that well
look at what mahomes did well my homes
came into a regiment situation where
they were winning 12 games
a year with alex smith and he had the
he had the the benefit of alex smith
being a wonderful mentor
a guy that coached him along the way and
then knew that he was coaching him into
his spot
he was going to leave so i think there's
a difference
in the way you build a team and i've
just been a believer in you have to have
an entire football team you have to have
an entire
roster and a good roster to take the
pressure off those young guys
otherwise you know you're destined to
fail to me it's one of those things and
i always look at organizations this way
you put a guy attention to fail then
don't ask
don't act shocked when he actually fails
if you put him in that position
mark schlereth here on the rich eisen
show pardon me three-time super bowl
champion mark schlereth here on the
wrist shot rich eisen show
in just one two minute video mark you
did better than your wikipedia page
could ever do to actually
educate people on your career
walk me through how you what a look even
even a jet fan die hard
as i am could i i laughed heartily
at your video walk me through your
production process for that
mark well you know it's funny because i
i i didn't realize i offended anybody
and it goes back to your former comment
where where i was like i was just
talking about football and generalities
and
just came up and the next thing i know
i've offended a whole fan base
which i think most jet fans got the
humor in it
so i literally flew out of arizona to
see
my former offensive line coach alex
gibbs um
and just uh just to catch up and then to
go visit him
yes and then i came back and um i came
back on
saturday evening and i had all these men
all these twitter messages people mad at
me and um
i i just said to myself well you know
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
uh sit down when i get home and and you
know
do a sarcastic apology and i literally
i literally grabbed my super bowl rings
walked into the study and
i have a you know some helmets uh all
the helmets that i wore in super bowls
they're sitting up there so i grabbed
one of the helmets and i i
literally did it in one take and uh and
i sent it to mcafee i go
what do you think oh man he's your
editor
he's your editor
you know there's part of me this is like
you know just let sleeping dogs lie
right and he goes dude you have to post
this this is hilarious
and and i actually i actually wait i
push the pause button even after senator
mcafee because
if he's not necessarily yeah you know
he's not necessarily the guy that you
want to
lean on for uh guidance right then i
sent it to my kids
who are older now okay they're all like
dad you got it you got to do it
so then i posted it and it just went
like you know it just went crazy
yes it did it's closing in on a million
views as we're sitting here
mark but in terms of just giving you an
idea because again i understand broncos
fans went through all those lean years
prior to la and then those years where
they thought elway was going to win it
and then didn't and then
obviously you and tyrell davis and a
whole bunch of others came along
um and you know the jets fans uh
uh can you you can't compare broncos
fans with jets fans in terms of
searching for somebody at least you had
elway at least you have rings i mean at
least you have those moments
like jets fans finally got the coach
right
with the giants championship head coach
and the patriots head coach who went to
the jets
with curtis martin got that right got
the quarterback and vinnie testaverdi
getting him to get the actual big time
play to finally come to roost that we
saw blossoming in cleveland right got
all of that
i was second to last row in the stadium
that day mark schlereth that led to that
middle finger ring of yours
two years into my sports center career
wearing my wesley
walker jersey that i had as a kid still
fit for my camp loconda and trails and
camp days sitting up there
i heard how deafening the silence was as
you trotted off to the locker room down
three nothing then
down ten nothing i did see the two
people
part of the lost fumbles on the day one
of them dave megat let an
ensuing kickoff after the first denver
touchdown
hit the turf that led to a fumble and
then another score
and then keith byers fumbling i mean i
could go on and on and on
the scars are there the middle finger
was flipped in that direction
and uh even i did laugh but that's who
you're dealing with
mark when you say that the new reset
doesn't matter
essentially right no i i completely i
completely get it and i think it does
matter and i don't know joe douglas the
gm
but like i said i'm a huge robert saul
the first thing i did when robert
sullivan got the job was texted
because i was so i was genuinely happy
for him
and you know one of the things that i
think um
that really sets you apart as a good
football team
rich is when you get to the point of
unselfishness where you can celebrate
somebody else's success like it was your
own
and that doesn't happen very often in
any walk of life that's cool
and when you become that tight as a
football team
i spent i told you i went to see my old
offensive line coach i spent
um i spent the night and a day with my
my backup in denver a guy named dave
diaz and fonte who coaches in the league
dave diaz and fonte um has the right
based upon our careers and our career
path
to loathe me to hate me
we effectively called him the stunt
guard because he practiced for me
wednesday thursday friday and i played
on the games on sunday
and we are best of friends we studied
together we prepared together
and he celebrates my success like it was
his own
and when i went out in 1997 with
herniated discs in l5
s1 both sides and had an operation 27
days later i was on the practice field
and i told mike shanahan a private
meeting if you think david is playing
better than me
then you need to continue to play him
for the rest of this playoff push and
i'll sit on the bench
but it means that much to me as a player
and when you're willing to make those
type of sacrifices you have the chance
to be a really good team
unfortunately there's very few
teams in any stretch of of life in any
uh organization or any league that are
willing to make those sacrifices for one
another
mark schlereth here on the rich eisen
show before i let you go sir
i'd be remiss if i didn't ask what you
think elway and the
and the broncos are evaluating at
quarterback sitting there at eight it's
entirely possible
that um a couple uh quarterbacks fall
as far as nine pardon me the panthers
are sitting there at eight they just did
get
sam darnold which i i i heard might have
been talked about on the mcafee show on
friday
but what do you think the broncos are
doing at nine and what elway's
evaluation of drew lock is as he's
apparently working with
peyton manning this season what do you
have for me on that front yeah
well george george payton obviously is
running the show now he's came out he
came over from
uh minnesota and so they're you know tag
tag teaming this situation but
i think ultimately i keep looking at
what george payton has done you know he
put his toe in the water
when it came to matthew stafford but he
didn't want to
he didn't want to pay the price right
when you're rebuilding a team and the
broncos frankly have not been very good
and you know people will point to the
last couple of drafts and say well look
at all the starters they got
well let me just say this bad teams
still have to start 22.
okay it's not like you say hey we only
have seven guys that are worth a crap
so we're only gonna start seven now you
still gotta start 11 on each side
so a lot of times you'll get duped into
believing we had a good draft because we
got all these starters well some of
those starters should be backups
and so when i look at the broncos over
the last few years under elway
they they are not they're not deep
enough they have not done a good enough
job in free agency or the draft
and so i think their roster is about 24
25 deep
what what i see is a guy that doesn't
want to jump in
to the fray and pay the price the san
francisco 49ers
look at what they got for all the to
move up from 12 to three
right and all the draft commodities they
gave up to do that
i don't think george payton is going to
do that i think he looks at it and says
i want to build a football team i think
he is more apt to trade
out of number nine back and pick up more
draft capital than he would be to move
up
and chase a quarterback i mean sometimes
drew locke looks terrific mark you know
like he
remember that time he went in um and
just boat raced the texans just
smoked him and we've seen some we've
seen some games out of him
where you know um against the chargers
and division which is always important i
mean we've seen it
i just don't know if do you do you think
elway thinks he is the guy
because i mean i i understand george
payton's in here but elway is the duke
right you know so
and that's the position here so what do
you think
i think i i think there's enough flashes
to where you're saying
like this is not an excuse but it's a
reason
you got to understand this kid has had
four different coordinators in college
right
in his first two years he's had two
coordinators in the pros
and the only way you learn what you like
and what you don't like rich when you
play is getting your ass kicked
like i get down to the red zone we run a
play and i get my ass kicked on i'm like
boy i don't like that play
i know the pitfalls of that play but the
only way i know the pitfalls of that
play is by playing
and you start to think about all the the
language you know in i mean you start
talking about
formations and you say hey tripp's right
nasty
h right outside two jet uh
two jet um branch buffalo
on three can it can it can it with uh
why with uh you know trips right nasty
wide
left 18 weeks on like there is
a ton of stuff that you have to know and
every time you say something you have to
have the vision and
just because you call something buffalo
you need to know the tight ends on the
through route he's our number one target
that f is on a pearl a pic pearl
and the z is running a now and you've
got to know hey if one side is zone
um you know and then i've got a man
beater on one side a zone beater on
there's so much to know when you change
an offense every year i talk to drew
lockbuster before i call the game
and he's like listen when i was at
missouri i didn't even have to know the
protections
everything was a seven man protection
like we're just chucking it deep
like all those things you have to learn
so i think there's enough patience to go
he has got the talent level can we
can we you know can we hone that and can
he start to understand
second year the first time he's been in
a bat in an offense for two years in a
row in the last six years
can he be can he be the guy i think
they're fixing to find out
okay mark before i let you go i know
we've been talking long enough
you got a good steve atwater story he's
in the we you know
missed him in the pandemic and
everything is the fact that he's a hall
of famer now
so you got a good one because he was on
the field that day and that and that
middle finger
uh super bowl ring run so what what do
you got right let's go back to the end
of that super bowl
steve atwater the end of that super bowl
knocked out randy hilliard
he knocked out i mean he knocked out
three players including himself
and we had to put three backups in the
game at that point
but the funny the funniest thing so when
chick
and atwater was there and uh and dennis
smith was there
um you know they all called him lumba
like lumber leg lumba yeah right and he
was really proud to have that nickname
lumba when he was a rookie because what
he thought it meant was he would bring
the wood
which obviously he would but they they
nicknamed him lumbo because he was stiff
as a board
and so there was there was always
there was always this they had this
internal joke that
you know that he was running around puff
chest because he thought they were
commenting on how hard he hit and they
were really commenting on how stiff he
was
so you know some of the little locker
room stuff that's always fun
but he was one he's one of the greatest
human beings
on the planet love steve atwater has a
unbelievable family
um unbelievable kids and his wife litha
amazing parents
and uh i tell you what he he was a
dispenser of justice
i mean that did you talk about a guy
that had blatant disregard for his own
well-being
he did not care he was gonna knock you
out
he was great he was an all-time great
and you know in the pandemic you forget
that he actually is getting in and we'll
hear his speech one day and
it'll be great hey mark i appreciate the
call uh the stinking truth podcast
um everybody should go download it where
all podcasts are acquired
and also that business of you um you
know going to
nfl teams and and working for them on
their run game i would scratch the jets
off your list
despite you liking robert sala i would
say that you put that a little bit in
danger but hey there's uh i guess what
20
uh 30 other teams you're good so um yeah
we're going to be fine we're going to be
fine clearly that video was great and
hey look and i know you got mcafee and
your kids i assume wingo is on the golf
course
so if you ever need anybody to maybe vet
uh something whether you're hovering
over the send button i'm i'm there for
you too
mark anytime hi rich i appreciate you
man
always like i said always great to catch
up and uh
i will i will give you uh just a quick
props on the way out
sure um you and everybody else when i
first walked off the football field
onto uh on to the broadcasting desk at
sportscenter and everywhere else
uh you guys were always so gracious to
me made me feel like family so
i appreciate your your peace
in my career as a broadcaster thank you
mark really appreciate that brother
let's do this uh seriously more often
let's not uh have you just flip off
uh the entire fan base that i'm a part
of to make me want to get you on the
show okay let's just do this for real
any time anytime you got it it's mark
schlereth everybody he's number one
he's number one
[Laughter]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here